okay well we're going to have another r
session this time we're going to look at
validation methods cross validation and
we'll
we'll start off with leave one out cross
validation
so we'll go to our our studio session
and and see what we can do with
validation
so
here we are
we first of all require islr there's our
data for our session
and this time we require the boot
package
and so require is just like
using library it will also return it
true and false if the package doesn't
exist
so let's look at the function cv.glm
so that's a general cross-validation
package for glms
and it'll give you some help on that and
so again it's always useful before you
use a package or use a function to look
at the help file and make sure you're
using it correctly
okay
so we're going to use the auto data and
in particular we'll look at two
variables miles per gallon
and horsepower so we'll make a plot of
those data and you know plot takes a
formula so you can use a formula in plot
and tell it where to to evaluate the
formula in the data set order so we make
that plot and we see as we might expect
miles per gallon
drops down
quite substantially as horsepower
increases okay
and
now we're going to investigate
we're going to use these dataset to
investigate the cross-validation
so the first thing we'll do is leave one
out cross validation
okay
and so we'll fit a linear model
and we'll use glm to fit this
even though we just fit in a linear
model so glm can fit non-linear models
as well
in particular logistic regression models
but it also fit linear models and so if
you don't give the family to glm by
default it just fits a linear model
okay
and then we'll run cv.glm
on that linear model
and
now just to remind you what c
that would
leave one out cross validation does
it
it fits the model repeatedly
n times if there's n observations each
time
it leaves out one observation
produces the fit on all the other data
and then makes a prediction
at the x value for that observation that
you left out
okay
and so
cv.glm
[Music]
actually does that by brute force
actually refits the model all those
times
it's a little slow you may have noticed
it took a while before the results came
up
and eventually it came up and it
produced two numbers we see them on the
screen here well it produced quite a lot
actually but we just looked at the delta
which is the cross-validated prediction
error
and even there it gives two numbers and
if you look on the help file you'll see
why the first number is the raw
leave one out or lu cross validation
result
and the second one is a bias corrected
version of it
and the bias correction is to do with
the fact that the data set
um that we train in on is is slightly
smaller than the one
than the one that we actually would like
to get the error for which is the full
data set of size n turns out that has
more of an effect for k-fold cross
validation
now the thing
is for leave one out cross validation
and for linear models
this
function doesn't exploit the nice simple
formula we saw
in in the chapter so
let me just remind you what that nice
simple formula is
and it goes like follows
we want the
the misclassification error
for each observation y i
minus
i'll write y
hat i
minus i
so this is what we'd like to compute
and we call that the leave one out
misclassified
sorry the leave one out sum of squared
errors
and this notation here y hat minus i
what it means is just what we said for
each observation
the ith observation you leave it out
you compute the fit using all the other
data and then you make it make a
prediction at that point so that's what
this notation refers to
and we have this really nice formula
that says that this is equal to 1 over n
summation
i'll make this explicit here i going
from 1 to n
it's the ordinary residuals
which i'll just write as y i hat
squared okay
so that these would be the ordinary
residuals if you didn't leave the
observations out so that just comes from
the least squares fit but now we have to
divide them by
1 minus
h i i
squared
and so this is like a magic formula
the hii that we have there is
the diagonal element of the hat matrix
the hat matrix is the operator matrix
that produces the least squares fit this
is also known as a self-influence it's a
measure of how much observation i
contributes to its own fit
and you notice what happens if if this
value these values h i i
vary between 0 and 1.
if h i i is close to 1 in other words
observation i really contributes a lot
to its own fit one minus h i i is small
and that will inflate that particular
residual
so this this is like a magic formula it
tells you that you can get your cross
validated fit by a simple modification
of the the residuals from the full fit
and that's much more
efficient
and cheaper to compute
okay so that's a slight detour now we're
going to write our own function to do
that okay
and that's formula 5.2 in the in the
book
so here we write our function we'll call
it
locv loo cv
takes the foot as an argument
and it uses a function called
lm.influence and that's a post processor
for for a lm fit and it'll extract
the element h from that which gives you
those diagonal elements h i i right so
we'll put that in a vector h
and then right on the fly we'll compute
that quantity on the right hand side
of our panel over there
first of all the residuals of the fit
give you the residuals from the from the
full fit so those are the terms in the
numerator
and then we divide by 1 minus
by 1 minus h
squared
and the residuals of fit is a vector
and 1 minus h is a vector
and the divide now does
element by element division in that
vector and we take the whole lot square
them and take the mean of that
and so that's going to be computing this
formula over here
okay so that we just build into our
function and then
and then
end off our function
and since that was the last quantity
computed that's will be what's returned
okay
so let's see if that works
we'll do lu cv
and lo and behold very quickly it
produced the 24.23 that we saw above for
the first element of of the results of
cv dot
glm so our function works okay great
so now we're going to use it and the way
we're going to use it is
we're going to fit polynomials of
different degrees
to to our data remember what the data
looked like
let's just go up here and plot it again
the data looks very non-linear
so we've plotted it again and now we're
going to fit some polynomials
of degrees one up to five right and so
we set ourselves up we've got a
vector for collecting the errors
okay
and now we
create the variable the degree which
take values one
2 5
and then we go in a loop for d
in degree
fit the glm
using a polynomial of that degree so we
use the poly function the function of
horsepower and degree
and then we use our little function to
compute the error
the leave one out cross validation error
and put it in in our error vector
okay
and look it's finished already it's done
all of them and if we plot this error
against degree
we see
that
degree 1 does pretty poorly
degree 2 jumps down from 24 down to just
above 19 and then higher degrees really
don't make much difference
and we might have guessed that looking
at the the plot of the data that a
quadratic would do a good job
okay well that was leave one out cross
validation let's try 10-fold
cross-validation now so recall with
10-fold cross-validation
you do actually much less work
what you do here is you make
you divide the data up into 10 pieces
and each tenth is a test set and the
nine tenths acts as a train inset
and in so for ten-fold cross-validation
you only have to fit the model ten times
with leave one out you have to in
principle fit the model n times where
n's the number of training points
although we did have the shortcut for
for linear regression
the reason cv.glm doesn't use that
shortcut is it's also set up to to work
on on logistic regressions and other
models and there the shortcut doesn't
work
okay so here we'll do 10 fold
and we'll again
set up a vector to collect our errors
and the same thing
go through the list we have a loop list
of degrees
fit our model
and now we'll actually use the cv.glm
function to to compute the the errors
and
so we call cv.glm and we tell it k is 10
so that tells the number of folds
okay
and that's pretty quick because it's
only fitting the model 10 times each
time
and now we'll include the errors on our
plot
we'll color them in red
and so we use the function lines
and it's not much different so in this
case ten fold and leave one out cross
validation pretty much told us the same
story
in general we favor tenfold cross
validation for computing errors
it tends to be a more stable measure
than leave one at cross validation and
for the most time it's it's it's cheaper
to compute